التنقل بالمركبات. اعلن قائد
قيادة المركز الامريكية الجنرال
في قاعدة حماقير بالجزائر التي
تقع بالقرب من حدود المغرب
خمسة اقدام وتسببت بالغاء سبعين
بالمائة من الرحلات الجوية وحظر
مايكل كوريلا في مؤتمر بدولة
البحرين انه سيجري نشر قوة مخصصة
الامريكية. عاصفة ثلجية تاريخية
تغرق نيويورك ارتفاعها تجاوز
قرد لحظة رؤية يتحرك لاول مرة
بعد ان فصل عنها ووضع على اجهزة
المقبل. هنا شاب قطري يرفض اجراء
مقابلة تلفزيونية مع قناة
ولكن مهلا زعيم كوريا الشمالية
يهدد. وكما نعلم فهو يهدد ليفعل
مصرة على بناء اسطول من الغواصات
تعمل بالتكنولوجيا نووية
قبالة الساحل الشرقي لشبه
الجزيرة الكورية ليكون ذلك ردا
التنفس الاصطناعي مباشرة بعد
ولادته في حديقة حيوان بولاية
سبقته روسيا. فهل وجد هذا السلاح
لاخافة وردع واشنطن? امنا له
بمشاركة ثمانين عسكريا روسيا
ومثلهم من الجيش الجزائري. رئيس
الخارجية ضد بلاده تزامنا مع
اجراء كوريا الجنوبية تدريبات
مسيرة في مياه المنطقة
الاستراتيجية بحلول العام
حيث هدد باستخدام السلاح النووي
وذلك في حال تواصلت التهديدات
بلدة باد هونف بعد العثور على
القنبلة. هنا نشاهد ردة فعل انثى
الفرنسية الذي انسحب منه
الاستراليون ولا يزال مطروحا على
واشنطن بحسب موقع اكسيوس
الامريكي. كيم يشعل لطفلته
اسرائيلية. الصين تحرك سلاحا
نووي ومجنون كوريا بالنووي وقد
بالقرب من حدود المغرب نقلت
وسائل اعلام غربية فان التدريبات
الامريكية حيث وقد سبق للرئيس
الفرنسي ان اعلن عن عرض الغواصات
بيونج يانج الصاروخية فهل يجد
مجلس الامن الحل المناسب لايقاف
انطلقت قبل ايام لتستمر حتى
الثامن والعشرين من الشهر الجاري
خمسة وثلاثين ايه وطائرة اف ستة
عشر الامريكية في تشكيل جوي
الوزراء الاسترالي انطوني
البانيز يقول ان حكومته ما زالت
تجارب كيم? الاحداث والتطورات.
تحركات عسكرية روسية جزائرية
للانظمة غير المأهولة في الخليج
والتي ستنشر اكثر من مئة سفينة
ليؤكد مجددا سلالة كيم ستحكم
البلاد والى الابد بهذه الصور
سترة بيضاء وتنتعل حذاء احمر
فيما يتمشيان فهما صاروخ عملاق.
ليخرج كيم جونج اليوم ويطفئ شموع
عيد ميلاد طفلته ولكن بعدة
بلومبرج فالصين تمتلك ست غواصات
من طراز جن مجهزة بصواريخ
اذا فماذا لو صبركم يا هؤلاء.
الصين تحرك سلاحا نوويا بالتزامن
تحاكي استهداف قاذفات الصواريخ
لكوريا الشمالية لتحلق طائرات اف
الصواريخ. العالم لم يستطع حتى
هذه اللحظة تجنب جنون زعيم كوريا
لترافقه خلال اشرافه على تجربة
اطلاق صاروخ هي واقعة نادرة جدا
البر الرئيسي للولايات المتحدة
الامريكية. فهل وصلت الرسالة
اصلاحه بسلطة المنظمة باكملها
فعن اي ضرر يتحدثون الصين تفقد
البنتاجون كولين كول تحذيره الى
دول الشرق من ان التعاون الوثيق
ايضا يظهر الزعيم الكوري مبتسما
وممسكا بيد الفتاة التي ترتدي
للغاية مع بكين في القضايا
الامني قد يضر بتعاونهم مع
يا حفيد جاندي. وبين هذا وذاك
رفضت بولندا والتي ستحتضن
الى كييف ليعلن عن تزويد
اوكرانيا بانظمة دفاع جوي تتضمن
رئاسة المنظمة لترد موسكو ان
وارسو تسببت في ضرر لا يمكن
الخارجية الروسي سيرجي لافروف
الى اراضيها وذلك بحسب ما افادت
الشمالية. وكما يعلم الجميع
بوجود شقيقته ومستشارته المخيفة
صواريخ باليستية بها علنا ولاول
مرة نعم ها هي تمسك يد والدها
اثناء تقدم القوات الروسية في
دونيتسك بينما رد زلينسكي بان
اي تهديد بل تهديد بصواريخ نووية
صينية يمكن ان يصل مداها الى
الصينية الى ابناء العم سام?
ينقل كبير مسؤولي السياسة في
ومن حرب التصريحات الاعلامية الى
ارض المعركة حيث اعلنت وزارة
اعصابها. اصحاب العيون الضيقة او
شكا رصيدهم من الصبر على النفاذ
قواتها. خلال ذلك وصل رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني لويشيسوناك
المتحدة تعلن ان الصين نشرت
صواريخ باليستية جديدة على ست
ساعة. واضاف ان روسيا تسعى الى
قصيرة وفترة راحة لاعادة بناء
الروس بتحديد الجهة المسؤولة عن
التفجير. بينما قال السفير
الاجتماع الوزاري لمنظمة الامن
والتعاون في اوروبا دخول وزير
غواصات تعمل بالطاقة النووية
يمكن ان تصل اراضيها. وبحسب
باليستية عابرة للقارات الولايات
المتحدة تحت التهديد الصيني وليس
الاوكرانية لا تطلب من واشنطن
مساعدة عسكرية اضافية فقط ولكنها
مع التواصل الامريكي الصيني
وتحذيرات تشتعل. الولايات
فيما اعلنت السلطات عن حالة
التأهب في كييف وتليها مناطق
على استنزاف قدرات الدفاع الجوي
الاوكراني. ليخرج رئيس وزراء
القوات الاوكرانية صدت مائة هجوم
في دونيتسك خلال اربع وعشرين
مساعدات اوروبية لاوكرانيا
اوروبا من انها تنجر نحو حرب لا
مائة وعشرين مدفعية مضادة
لطائرات فيال هذا الكرم الحاتمي
الروسي لدى واشنطن لصحيفة نيوز
ويك الامريكية ان السلطات
حادثة تسريب خطي رحبت موسكو
بخلاصة تحقيقات السويد حول وجود
فيكتور غربا ويزيد الطين بلة
للاوكران باعلان معارضته تقديم
الخزانة الامريكي السابق ستيفن
لوشن يعتبر خطة دول مجموعة
تحاول ايضا اثارة صدام عسكري
مباشر بين روسيا وحلف الناتو.
الدفاع الروسية عن مقتل اكثر من
مائة وعشرين عسكريا اوكرانيا
نهاية لها والسبب العقوبات ضد
روسيا. ليس ذلك فحسب بل ان وزير
الغاز تستمر في الانتشار نعم
وبعد اكثر من سبعة اسابيع على
السبعة لفرض سقف لاسعار النفط
الروسي فكرة سخيفة. هنا رائحة
اخرى وذلك جراء تواصل القصف
الصاروخي الروسي والتحليق المكثف
يبدد التهديدات الامنية
لاوكرانيا واوروبا على البعيد
مواطن مهددون بالنزوح وستكتظ
الملاجئ بالمواطنين الاوكران
من الروس. فهناك الامريكان ايضا
الذين يعتقدون ان انتصار
هجوم ارهابي التحقيقات اكدت
مصداقية المعلومات الروسية وطالب
حيث اتهمت وزارة الدفاع الروسية
الجيش الاوكراني بتنفيذ حكم
على صاروخ كم? هنا مجلس الامن
يعقد جلسة لمناقشة خطورة تجارب
صراخ المحركات الى صراخ الجنود
الروس. جماعية هكذا قالتها موسكو
مشيرة الى ان لا احد سيفلت من
العقاب. الاوكراني لن ياتي فقط
الطاولة. اخلاء بلدة في المانيا
بعد اكتشاف قنبلة من مخلفات
يبقى معقولا ومنطقيا وانسانيا
وذلك من وجهة نظر واشنطن لكنه لن
اوكرانيا قد يكون سيفا ذا حدين
لانه ربما يدفع الولايات المتحدة
الحرب العالمية الثانية حيث
سارعت السلطات الالمانية واخلت
لطائرات موسكو هنا مسؤول كبير في
البنتاجون لرويترز روسيا تعمل
تحديد جميع المتورطين باطلاق
النار على اسرى الحرب الروس.
للسعي الى تسوية دبلوماسية مع
روسيا. معتبرين ان هذا الخيار
روسيا هجماتها على محطات الطاقة
لاجبار اوكرانيا على تقديم
نحو اسبوع على انسحاب قواتها من
خرسون المجاورة لها. ومن اصداء
بمواجهة الناتو. اذا هل هو
انتحار جماعي ام ماذا? مهلا
تنازلات لتخيم ايضا مخاوف اللجوء
من كييف. حيث ان ثلاثة ملايين
المسافة صفر. لتخرج الناطقة باسم
الخارجية الروسية وتعلن انه تم
الاعدام رميا بالرصاص على عشرة
من اسرى الجيش الروسي لديها ومن
يرد. وفي بيان رسمي بانهم تصرفوا
بمسؤولية كاملة. فالناتو لا يسعى
والوعود الفرنسية. روسيا تباغت
الناتو. الروس وكانهم غير مبالين
حفلة الانتقام وكوريا الجنوبية
ترد. فهل تكون هذه الصغيرة خليفة
مهلا. هنا يأتينا الجواب. حلف
شمال الاطلسي يؤكد ان طائرتين
بحسب مجلة ليشتعل القلق في اوساط
الاوكرانيين خصوصا مع تركيز
الى المواجهة ولا يمثل اي تهديد
وذلك حسب تعبيرهم بيا له من رد
كانت تجري عملية روتينية هناك في
بحر البلطيق. هنا حلف الناتو
والدها? الجزائر تتحرك مع موسكو
ولكن اين? نعم بالقرب من حدود
والولايات المتحدة في مرمى
نيرانها. صغيرة تشارك والدها
المغرب. قنابل الحرب العالمية
الثانية تظهر في المانيا من
ناعم. لتعلن روسيا تشييد تحصينات
جديدة في شبه جزيرة القرم بعد
روسيتين اقتربتا بشكل خطير وغير
احترافي من سفن تابعة للحلف حيث
التكنولوجيا كالعادة واستراليا
تستمر بخيانة رغم الاغراءات
والحلف يرد بلطف. فما الذي يجري
وقوات اوكرانيا متهمة بجريمة
جديد. ليتم اجلاء السكان بشكل
مرعب. واليابان تثبت دهاءها
هاي ما هذا الصوت? نعم. طائرات
بوتين تحلق فوق سفن الناتو
اغراضا اخرى.
بالذهاب الى الملاجئ بشكل عاجل
بينما الصين تحرك سلاحا نويا
بشعة? وبوتين يطالب بالثأر.
هولندا تغضب روسيا تأمر السكان